very very smart people they prep for an
interview or negotiation or a
presentation and they prep their ideas
they want their ideas to be amazing
right they're pitching to their boss or
their team they want to have their dream
job and they're like i have to have the
perfect answer and so they script out
the perfect answer and they go in there
and they're blindsided they don't know
why they're giving the perfect answers
but people are on their computer
checking their email
they're not getting any nods
or any
uh smiles or any leans or not seeing any
of those warmth because they're like
what's going on and that's just like
jamie siminoff if you are smart you
might run into this problem where people
underestimate you and your ideas because
you are not delivering them
with the right competence and warmth